one of the biggest questions around the
world for humans as people is being
happy how can you be happier what
contributes to happiness what's a
distraction to trying to achieve
happiness that we shouldn't worry about
thousands and thousands of these pseudo
informative articles go viral all the
time these five things really increase
happiness or 10 tips to increase
happiness from the happiest monk in the
world or whatever the first time now for
the first time now we have something
being described as happiness genes which
have been identified there's been a
really big study involving a hundred and
ninety researchers in 140 research
centers across seventeen countries and
some very specific genetic variants have
been located and associated with not
only happiness but other traits as well
this is published in the new issue of
the journal Nature and it's identified
genetic variants that are associated not
only with happiness but also feelings of
well-being depression and neuroticism it
was also found that gene variants are
mainly expressed in sent in the tissues
of the central nervous system as well as
adrenal and pancreas tissues this was a
meta-analysis done it came from the data
of a huge study involving almost 300,000
people sometimes we hear something like
this and people will say oh so it's all
completely genetic rarely typically what
these studies point to is that there are
genes for predispositions to certain
traits or characteristics we've talked
about this predispositions to
psychiatric conditions bipolar disorder
schizophrenia which can sometimes be
sort of turned on to use a layman's term
or triggered by life situations or they
can remain dormant for someone's entire
life so this is just the first step in
what will undoubtedly be very very
interesting research and you have to
remember the impact of one genetic
variant is very very small with IQ
studies with the idea of making people
super-smart by modifying genetic markers
you would have to modify hundreds and
hundreds of markers to predispose
someone to
have an even marginally higher IQ that
doesn't mean that if you trigger or move
all the right genetic variants it
wouldn't have a significant impact but
we have to think about this in the grand
scheme of things so this is very
interesting and of course real questions
as we think about the future of these
types of trials what are the ethics of
it what are the morals of it and what
are the sort of societal implications
just a first step
much more on this coming I'm sure
Gamefly is sort of like Netflix for
video games they have over 8,000 new and
classic games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4
ps3 Wii and a bunch of other platforms
and you can play as many games as you
want for one monthly fee and if you find
some games you want to keep you can buy
them for a low used price there's never
any due dates or late fees and our
audience can get a free 30-day trial at
Gamefly offer.com slash TDPS the games
are shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the David Pakman show audience and
support our show by going to Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s